my guest today is dr yara haridi
some of you probably know her from
twitter she is an evolutionary
paleontologist she studies fossils more
specifically she is a paleo histologist
histology is the study of plant and
animal tissue under a microscope you
look at a microscopic biological
structure and try to understand
macroscopic function from what's going
on down there at the cellular level the
tissue level her focus lately has been
on bone growth and bone remodeling she
studies this in fossil organisms
remodeling is when bones repair and
reshape themselves throughout an
organism's life even once you're done
growing your bones do not just become
dead rocks under your skin they are
living tissue far more alive even than
your hair or your fingernails your
skeleton is spectacularly responsive to
your lifestyle choices your bones are
capable of constantly reshaping to meet
your needs and for some crazy reason
nobody seems to be talking about how
amazing this is
well thank goodness you clicked on this
video because you are about to get over
an hour almost an hour and a half
of mind-blowing information about your
skeleton and you're going to get that
information from the brilliant doctor
yara haridi
yara i am extremely happy to have you on
here today you're going to give us kind
of a little mini lesson on how it is
that bone remodeling works so behind me
i've got some skulls and
they're from different age periods of
different animals and so we can actually
look at how
remodeling works throughout an animal's
lifetime so i'm very excited to learn
about this but first i just wanted to
hear from you how do you describe
yourself first thanks for having me on
i'm actually so excited i'm always
excited to talk about bones but i'm
extra excited to talk about remodeling
because it's actually an aspect that
nobody really asks me about
so in general how would i describe
myself that's a really good question
i find it sometimes hard to fit into the
paleontologist's stencil
but i would mostly describe myself as a
paleontologist and an evolutionary
biologist
but i definitely haven't always been
that way i didn't have you know the
dinosaur stage that all kids have or was
i was never interested in fossils
growing up i didn't even really
know what it was i didn't really know a
whole lot of stem things my family
didn't really do museums it just wasn't
part of growing up
so uh how did i get to paleontology
basically i was studying to go to
medical school i come from an immigrant
background and it's just you know a good
way to make your parents proud and show
them that all their sacrifices were
worth something so studying to go to
medical school
and
i hated it i hated it so much
one of the only places i could volunteer
to gain more experience in anatomy was
ironically a vertebrate paleontology lab
so i volunteered and fell in love with
the topic and
got my masters in vertebrate
paleontology at the university of
toronto
and then moved on to getting my phd
which is what i'm doing now in berlin
the natural history museum in berlin and
so how did i get to bone specifically
basically it was a very roundabout way
which had a nice stop at teeth so i'm
always interested in development how
things change over time and the thing
that made me really fall in love with
paleontology was that you can ask these
big questions how did things change over
the millions of years the things that we
have now the things i'm learning in my
medical textbooks the things that we
take as fact and always was and the way
we work and the way our skeletons work
the way our muscles work all of it you
can ask insane long-term questions about
why did it get this way and how did we
get here and
what things changed over time and uh i
applied that to teeth
uh and that's what my master's is about
the evolution of certain types of teeth
and now i'm applying it to bones because
it's kind of the basis of paleontology
at least vertebrate paleontology
so
that's how i got here
what species teeth have you been looking
at so for my masters i started with
these permian reptiles that had very
specific teeth that kind of looked like
little hershey's kisses and they're just
sitting on top of the jaw and nobody
really knew how those teeth were placed
because although we only like us mammals
we only lose our teeth once in our life
most animals continuously replace their
teeth
so it's assumed that this animal also
did that but we didn't really know how
that worked so i looked at um bearded
dragons and a gametes and chameleons and
stuff because they're known to be modern
reptiles that don't replace their teeth
and i kind of did some comparisons and
figured out that the permian guy doesn't
actually not replace his teeth he does
but you know it's in a very cryptic way
and that's basically what my master's is
on oh nice
so is it is it true that all mammals
only shed teeth once
there are exceptions to every rule
so
the fun exceptions are manatees dugongs
um some kangaroo species um
and then the opposite side of that scale
is some types of shrews actually replace
their baby teeth um like the tooth
starts to grow as a nub in the womb and
then when they come out they're already
like ready to have their adult teeth so
those are the exceptions
um that i know of i'm sure there's more
but so the manatees doing it
continuously
yeah they're kind of because they're
kind of closer to elephants where they
have like these teeth at the back that
kind of move
forward continuously because elephants
also do this they have this set number
they don't have just forever
continuously
regenerating teeth but they have a set
number that slowly move forward as they
wear away the front ones and so there is
technically like a conveyor belt a
really slow one uh of teeth just going
forward because if you don't have
continuous teeth you starve when you're
eating tough stuff
and then
rodents
you know rodents i mean their front
teeth are continually growing do they
actually lose them too at a point or do
they just have one set of questions
oh i don't know
i feel like they must lose their their
first step i really don't know i
actually don't know they are the weird
the weirdest
probably well as far as teeth go the
weirdest
actually i shouldn't say that because
we've got things like narwhal
there's all sorts of weird teeth out
there but yeah mammals do some weird
stuff with their teeth that's for sure
yeah yeah i want to talk about bone
remodeling and
before i do that i just want to kind of
show off my
bone these are all
none of these are real skulls they're
all replicas
but
there's some things in here that have
just really got me curious about how it
is that
skeletons are restructured throughout an
organism's lifetime i know that
remodeling of bones is happening
constantly there was there was an
interview with chris hadfield who was
the astronaut the canadian astronaut he
was saying that the first week that
you're in space you just pee out
calcium because your bones are trying to
remodel they don't know what's happening
in the zero gravity
that got me really curious
but then this skull right here
this is from a peruvian her head was
bound when she was a baby and that's how
her skull got elongated like this
it's funny because people on the
internet say these are aliens but
obviously they're just humans with
elongated skulls the really fascinating
thing about her is that her skull is not
abnormally large it looks abnormally
large but if you actually measure it my
my nephew and i did a video where we
measured this using archimedes principle
and we compared it to a normal human
skull and we found that hers is actually
slightly smaller than the the other
skull that we had but completely within
normal human brain size range
she was just a small person
but yeah for those watching if you
haven't seen these series science versus
the aliens of peru i highly recommend it
it's pretty fun we looked at all the
different internet claims that people
have saying that these things are aliens
and then we compared them to the actual
data
here
i have a juvenile chimpanzee the top of
the skull is very round and smooth and
here i have a mature chimpanzee
and he has this beautiful
sagittal crest on the top
that's just you know kind of like a bone
mohawk
yeah it totally is in the gorilla that's
just
absolutely extreme huge crest up here
and in both of these animals and chimps
and gorillas that does not exist when
they're young in fact i've got a
this here is a baby gorilla and his
skull is shaped just like a human's
actually
so
sorry this is a this one's a chimpanzee
i've got a gorilla over there
but
this fact that
bones are constantly changing shape is
spectacular not all animals can do this
is that correct
uh sort of so not all animals
can do a certain other type of
remodeling so we can get into it um
there's different kinds of remodeling
one called one that most people think of
which actually causes most of their
remodeling in our body and it's called
osteonor remodeling and all that means
is it's led by osteons it's actually led
by your blood vessels invading the bone
and carrying cells with them that
destroy and rebuild bone we'll talk
about that more in detail because that's
the one that does a lot of heavy lifting
in our skeleton
but the less known one and that's what
my publication was about which is why i
talk about it a little bit more often is
peri lacunar remodeling which so
basically osteocytes bone cells live in
these little caves
and they can remodel the cave that they
live in and the cave is obviously made
of bone because they live in our bones
and they monitor our bones and they you
know check out if there's too much
stress or not enough calcium and if your
bone needs remodeling they're the ones
that send out the alarm for for these
cells to come and do remodeling but what
they actually can do themselves is that
they can take away calcium and phosphate
from the walls and recirculate it back
into the system and this is happening on
a cellular scale it's super super tiny
so all they're doing is just etching the
outside of their environment and sending
that but when you consider that aside
from like neurons and other cell types
like osteocytes are the longest lived
and very numerous
cells in our skeleton uh it does have an
impact on your metabolism so that's one
type of remodeling but
this the really interesting and um and
the one that we can see very often is
this osteonal remodeling this type which
basically forms all these blood vessels
coming through
your bone and they carry with them at
the very front of them they carry
osteoclasts so that's how they bury
through the bone they basically do these
like mold tunnels through your bone and
then they send out osteoblasts on the
outside and they rebuild and that's how
you end up remodeling old bones so say
you had an old wall they tunnel through
that old wall and then rebuild on their
way out and they do it in like a really
interesting like zipper motion so you
open it like it's open on one side and
they start to close it off as they go
along
so
yeah and and that's how we
we basically get a new skeleton
every seven to ten years until you're
like 25 or something along those lines
and it depends on the type of bone and
it's just continuously recycling
continuously renewing one of your
questions is how do you get
you know crests on one animal and not
the other or over
ontogeny as they're growing up
why are they getting crusts yeah yeah so
yeah let's talk about the crest first
because it seems to be pressure from the
mussels the chewing muscles that causes
the crest to grow because they start out
when they're young they have the muscles
just on the side of the head
and as they go through puberty those
muscles enlarge and they creep up they
get so big they creep up the skull
and it seems like somehow by pulling on
the skull that triggers the cells to be
like oh we need to build more bone here
and that that process is just mysterious
to me
so only recently was there a paper that
talks about how muscle and bone talk to
each other on a molecular level what
hormones are sent across to have that
communication
because we know our muscles
have an influence on our bone
that's why you know
if you work out you get denser bones if
you go to space and you're not using
your muscles against your bone as much
you get
less dense bones
so
we know that the two talk to each other
we just don't really know how we don't
know if it's something that's introduced
by the muscle or something that's sent
out by the bone
there are several ways that that kind of
goes on but what you're looking at in
that crest is a muscle attachment site
and it's known that muscle attachment
sites will get more robust uh based on
pressure so kind of like you said it's
they're not exactly pushing up the bone
and they're not exactly pulling at the
bone
but what they're doing is even if you
have like the tiniest little crest and
you have a little bit of muscle that's
attached to it as it's being as the
muscle is working you know flexing and
loosening up and flexing and loosening
up it actually puts pressure on the
periosteum there the thin layer that
covers all our bones and has the living
cells in it
and that tells the bone hey this is an
important spot make it bigger make it
rougher so we can attach more things so
that's how you get some of those crazy
crests on those primates but it's also
how you get really intense attachment
sites on arms and
legs and stuff
in fossils and that's how we reconstruct
muscular the musculature of extinct
animals we follow these
areas these areas that are bumpy and
lumpy and that's how we know okay this
is bumpy and lumpy because a muscle
pulled on it a whole lot
so now we know that that must connect to
something here and that must connect to
something here so that's
it's a good question because
muscle attachment sites are incredibly
important
yeah if you were looking at a human
skeleton could you tell if the person
was a weightlifter versus you know
regular joe
would that would that actually show up
it would it definitely would would i be
able to tell you'd probably want to talk
to a um
like anthropologist
like just because i'm not as familiar
with human anatomy but yes you
definitely can there's even papers that
they look at skeletons of like people
from medieval times and look at the
robustness of the ephemera the like
bones and how thick the cortical bone is
and they can tell okay this person was
you know working hard labor uh and that
you know corresponds with the type of
burial we found them in and that kind of
stuff does show up in your bones your
skeletons record our lives i read a
paper a long time ago years ago
they found
a broken bone that had healed
on a human
and
there was a certain structure in the
face that made it look like for years
they had this painful wincing expression
on their face that could actually show
it actually showed up in the bones when
someone had is in pain they move their
face in a certain way
and that can that tugs on the bone a
little bit and they said they can
actually read that in the face i don't
know
how um like disputed that claim is but
they they're like oh yeah this person
was in misery their whole life isn't
that awesome oh god
i mean that's yeah that's uh that's
ancient osteology for you i kind of say
the same thing a lot about animals like
oh look at this pathology like that it's
so cool this animal lived its whole life
then you realize you're like not the
nicest thing
but um i don't i don't know about that
particular paper especially because in
the face the human face a lot of the
muscles are so fine and they're smooth
muscles it's like they're not these like
strong tugging muscles i really wonder
if
they would make that kind of impact on
osteology but i wouldn't i wouldn't rule
it out i'd have to read the paper but
that sounds really cool
so after my conversation with yara i
looked this up
it turns out that i did not read about
this in a paper
i watched it in a nova documentary on
pbs
and
scientists do not agree you can't
actually tell someone's facial
expressions unfortunately based on their
skull
but in the nova special they did think
you could and they said this they say in
the case of kenobi man evidence for
severe injuries suggested that the man
lived many of his 40-plus years in
frequent if not chronic pain he had a
bunch of broken bones he had indications
that he got stabbed with a spear all
sorts of stuff prominent muscle markings
above the chin and beneath the eye
sockets confirmed this revealing a face
held in an expression of determined
endurance
for this reason our approximation shows
the weariness of a middle-aged man in
perpetual discomfort that's a pretty
cool sculpture
but their claim is contradicted by this
paper facial reconstruction anatomical
art or artistic anatomy which goes over
the what we can and cannot trust in
these facial reconstructions these are
really cool by the way it's pretty
impressive what can be done but you
cannot get enough detail to figure out
what type of facial expression a person
was making during their life
so here we have this huge on the top of
the skull here
we've got this huge crest which
so what you're saying is that this
it's the it's the tissue on the outside
of the bone that is getting that signal
and is trying to
grow in accommodation to that
uh that that seems very different than
what must be actually maybe it's not
that different than what's happening in
an elongated skull it seems to me
that
the brain as the brain is growing it is
also somehow communicating with the
skull case
and telling it when it can stop growing
because
you know we have
here you can literally just bind a
baby's head and it will grow long
instead of
round
which must mean that the bone is being
instructed by pressure from the brain or
by the internal organ the bone actually
is probably being instructed
instructed by the pressure from the
binding itself
it's hypothesized that human skulls
ossify together
later
than other primates because our brains
tend to grow
larger proportionally to our skulls
so
basically how our skulls fuse is that
when you're born skulls are made of all
these little plates and you probably see
it in your casts you have um all these
sutures right all the little zigzags
where the bones eventually met
but
those zigzags exist because those bones
initially didn't meet they actually had
soft tissue soft tissue in between and
that's why you know babies have those
soft spots at the top of their heads
that people tell you not to press but
it's like really tempting anyway um
don't do it
but uh
we have several fontanelles we have one
at the top we have one at the back um
the one that everyone knows is the one
at the top but we actually have them at
several spots including the temples
um
and that is probably how you get that
elongate shape so because you're putting
pressure
on the frontal bones um here and here it
can push out and kind of form those soft
areas because you're not working with
plates that are attached to each other
you're working with floating plates and
then if that's if that continues to stay
bound which i assume that culture you
know left them bound for a long time
yeah i think it's two years yeah or
maybe even longer yeah
i i would assume probably longer but at
that point the bonus has no option but
to ossify into the shape that it is kind
of kept in
uh and the brain just kind of
adapts to filling that space
and i'm not actually surprised that like
i like i would be super surprised if
those people
had any you know
brain deficits or anything like that
yeah one of the things that is neat
about these elongated skulls is they
they tend to have a really big i forget
the name of it there's a hole in the
back of some people's skulls
and these ones usually have a really big
one for a blood vessel to get into
parietal foramen that's what they're
called only some people have them and
these elongated skulls tend to have
extra large parietal foramen you were
saying earlier that uh blood vessels can
actually be summoned through bone and
bore through bone
can that happen at any time of life
it has to happen at all points of life
because that's how we actually remodel
our skeleton so think about it this way
once your skeleton is laid down once you
have a bone that's laid down and it's
like a concrete block
how are you actually going to take
material out and like say you have micro
cracks in this concrete block now and
you want to go in and fix these micro
cracks yeah because you know eventually
they might you know each tiny crack
connects to the next one and then you
have a problem
so you want to fix these before they
become a problem how do you do that you
actually have to like you said and i
love this word summon um
like blood vessels through this hard
material and have a way of basically
recycling minerals inside so that's what
they do they you have a hard block and
they have these vessels that burrow
through these hard blocks and find where
the
where the micro cracks happened and take
away all that damaged tissue and
redeposit new tissue
and that's why usually you will never
get no not never but very unlikely that
you get a break in the same spot
because that area has been remodeled and
it's kind of similar to
so if you if you know anything about
planes if a plane has a hole in it or a
crack in it what they actually do is
they make more holes around that hole
because it helps dissipate the pressure
and it helps whatever pressure is
happening to actually move around it so
bones did that first
basically they have all these vessels
around that area and that area becomes
stronger because it's been redeposited
and rebuilt and fixed a bunch of times
it's more likely that the area beside it
will crack or somewhere else will crack
but almost never the exact same spot
that's interesting
more on the skull size that accommodates
the brain have you seen or heard of
these cases of hydrocephaly where the
the skull gets huge
their skull will be maybe like twice as
the size of a normal skull
because they're getting they call it
water in the brain it's just you're
making too much spinal fluid that does
suggest that the skull is growing based
on pressure within it as opposed to some
sort of a pre-programmed
size that the bone is going to grow
so yes i know most of these kids like
unless they're yeah i mean usually
they're people try to keep them alive
and and then you know eventually the
skull ossifies
bone will try to meet them
that condition starts basically from
birth or like within a couple months
and and it starts to separate because
again those bones were never fused
so
they separate and separate and then
eventually the bone tries to grow
together
that isn't to say there is supposed to
be a predetermined size there kind of is
a predetermined size but it's based on
several factors it's based on partially
your brain partially a timing of
ossification
i mean maybe even if you had a normal
sized head but you delayed ossification
in the skull maybe your brain would grow
bigger i'm i don't think so there's
probably research into this but i think
it's multiple factors that then kind of
give us the average human brain size or
average human skull size yeah yeah
actually the
i was talking to the bone clones guys
about
because they actually have one of the
specimens is one of these it
he was an adult he died in his 30s which
is super rare
usually you either have to treat it
right away
or you'll die and this guy somehow lived
to his 30s but they said that when they
got the skull it was almost paper thin
in some spots of course yeah and so they
had to be it it was really hard for them
to make a cast of it because you have to
put it in this
plastery rubbery stuff
um and they don't want to crush it of
course right
so it was uh
that is interesting so the skull i mean
it was it is
insanely huge
it's it's unbelievable this is a human
but it's it's
like like he was saying it's it actually
did cause problems for the skull it's
not not a nice thick skull like you
would you would hope and that's one of
the reasons why these people have such a
difficult time surviving the condition
because they could they could get it or
they could get a
brain bruise i guess really easily
i mean i assume there's a lot more
problems than just having a thin skull i
mean having that much pressure on your
brain can not be good yeah i think now
it's it's early the early treatment for
it now is just a shunt to kind of take
out as much of the fluid as possible i
don't know what the more permanent
treatment is but it
i mean i'm a big fan
fan sounds horrible but i'm super
interested in pathologies for this exact
reason right they help us understand
what is normal or why
we actually get the normal physiology
because
if you if all you have is normal skulls
you don't get these questions right you
don't get why
why does bone do this or why does bone
do that um so like for example one of
the really interesting things is uh bone
breaks because they're quite common you
know almost everybody's broken a bone
and that also has to do with remodeling
so
when your bone breaks the two ends at
some point are either not meeting let's
say it's a full break rather than
fraction
and then your bone has to try to kind of
overcome that gap without shortening
your limb because
short limbs are not really great for
especially for us bipedals it's not it's
not the way to go so
you know your bone instantly freaks out
and sends a bunch of swelling to kind of
hold the
ends apart
and then it pushes out cartilage to kind
of make um a stencil of a callus
and then after that it will cover that
in bone
all that just to stabilize the outside
before it can start to rebuild in
internally it's kind of like making um
what is it called
uh when people put up
scaffolding scaffolding thank you
yeah so it's like when people put up
scaffolding just to like paint the
building just to like actually get
the person up to the point that it needs
to be it's like they're doing the same
thing for cells and blood vessels
they're just like stabilizing the two
and actually i have a broken bone here
if you want to see it
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i i snapped my arm uh
i don't think mine would have healed at
all i snapped it way too good but
um
i yeah how are you doing skateboarding
when i was like 15 i was in a half pipe
and my hand was on my elbow so
it completely folded
and when it folded back it was kinked
like this so i had an s-shaped arm
i don't think that
my biology could have fixed that without
intervention
no probably not no no probably not um
especially because our forearms are
actually the most complex in the way
where you know if we if we have our arm
like this or like supinated then you
know our bones are normal and straight
but if you turn it then our bones
crisscross so you have to like not only
have them stretched out
apart but you need to like be completely
immobile
so you don't have the wrong bone ends
fusing to each other or having all all
four ends fused in one big knot yeah
which is no fun for anybody
so what i'm going to show you here is a
fossil
it is a cave bear so not not super super
old
uh but it's um
it's only like actually i don't remember
but it's a european cave bear and he
didn't have a good time
so
if you can see that
oh wow
so basically here is the one end of the
femur
wow
and here's the other end and what
happened was probably something similar
to what you described which is yeah the
bone snapped and then as you can see
there's a shortening right so it this
area slid down
um
and and basically
the union is incomplete and it tried to
form a callus it tried to kind of
get around it
but to re-elongate that bone would
basically be impossible
right
so this was a juvenile animal we can
tell because of
the way that the top of the femur looks
it hadn't fully ossified the top
so it's a juvenile animal that had a bad
time it tried to heal for a while so you
can tell that you know it survived long
enough to at least heal this much
but
maybe you know the short limb
uh eventually didn't help or maybe the
winter was too harsh or something but
yeah i thought i always find pathology
super interesting because they tell you
about the animals they tell you about
the people they tell you about normal
biology it's just there's so many
stories and just one specimen yeah
that is really neat that's that is
brutal that poor guy oh ouch
when we're studying paleontology
how much can
an animal's activity during its life
change its skeleton i mean is it
possible for us to think that we're
looking at two different species when
actually we're just looking at the same
species that lived in very different
conditions
so it changed throughout its lifetime
that's a really good question it's
almost like a nature versus nurture
situation right
um so i think of it kind of like
we have a set stencil we have a set
structure we have a set plan
there is a certain amount of wiggle room
in certain directions
but it's not so crazy
that
you really
if you know the biology of the animal
well
it's it's quite hard to to really think
that once but species is is different
from another that being said with
paleontology a lot of the times we don't
know the biology that well right
sometimes we only have one specimen of
this one animal
and
two three four five years later we find
another specimen that looks similar but
not quite
and and it's difficult it's very
difficult to realize you know where do
you set the line where yeah
how much difference equals a different
species versus not and and in reality in
some ways we're probably overestimating
species because we don't know um
ontogeny we don't know their growth
series very well
and in
other ways we're probably
underestimating um
diversity of species because if you look
at like modern animals and lizards a lot
of them
are completely different species you
know their outside is different their
behavior is different they live in
different niches especially i like the
example of anils because
in one tree you have the branch animals
you have the ones that live near the
trunk you have the ones that live at the
canopy and they're making all these
different niches across one tree they
all look different they all
behave differently but their skulls are
so similar
so similar
but they're different species like we
know they're different species we know
they're different species because we
have genetics and we have the external
looks and the behavior and all these
other factors that you don't get
with fossils yeah right and also
when you look at their so when you look
at their skeletons they're they're very
similar but we also have a full skeleton
for them now cut that skeleton into
maybe less than 20 of it put it in a
rock tumbler and tell me if you can
still
figure out if it's a different species
or not right that's the challenge that
paleontologists have
so
that's good
i used to work i used to volunteer at a
wildlife rehabilitation center and so we
would deal with you know injured birds
of all kind injured mammals
uh pretty much anything we weren't
allowed to work with wolves or deer or
possums because possums were considered
nuisance and coyotes were considered
nuisance and then wolves and deer were
just too big for us but we we dealt with
pretty much everything else in the state
of oregon
we had an osprey come in who didn't did
that didn't make it
and
the guy that i was working with the guy
who runs the place he was showing me it
it had a broken humerus this is the
humerus right yeah had a broken humerus
so the upper arm bone and he was showing
me that's got these little uh it's a
very hollow bone but it has these they
look like bicycle spikes yeah these
struts that go across
he was telling me that those form
according to how that individual happens
to hit the water when it's hunting so
those spokes will change over time he
says that every time he looks at one
it's it's slightly different
and
he thinks that it's it's remodeling i
don't know if if that sounds like a
legitimate
hypothesis to you i mean it does it does
in a way where um
i would not be surprised especially
early on in the animal's life so so bird
bones in general are quite hollow uh
pterosaurs are the same way and they
have struts um
to kind of prop up the inside of the
bone and distribute the pressure without
not without adding extra weight
because you know one way to make your
bones strong is just to make them thick
but if you really want to get um air
bound you're not gonna want to add all
that weight so the way they do it is
they add all these struts
now it's interesting because there is a
couple of studies that show okay like
here's an ulna of a vulture and we know
the way vultures hold their wings
because you know they kind of soar and
they do it one way and there isn't a
whole lot of external differences in
pressure and so they scanned these bones
and they saw that yeah okay the struts
are you know uh placed in areas of high
pressure because we can actually test
possibly where pressure is uh based on
the bone shape so i i don't think that's
a crazy hypothesis i wonder how much of
it does change because
as as you're remodeling something you're
taking stuff away and you're adding so
you have to
do it at a rate that isn't weakening the
bone right so the way we have
osteoporosis is that the remodeling is
happening so fast that you're doing a
lot of the taking away without doing a
lot of the adding so i would assume this
would be a problem for diving birds
where you know
their remodeling just has to be at a
good enough pace
um
i think he was saying
it's been a long time since i had this
conversation with him but i think he was
saying that the juveniles have more than
the adult so it's like the juveniles
have them all over the place randomly
and the adults have them only in
specific positions according to how
they've been hunting
i would not be surprised that would
totally make sense to me i mean yeah if
the juveniles kind of went
all out with making struts at the
beginning and then the biology kind of
like biology of the bone kind of narrows
it down and takes away the ones that are
not useful and that actually happens in
us as well so um the our ephemeral like
the top of the femur where it hits or
inserts into the hip
it has all these struts that are
optimized for our type of walking
and it distributes the the pressure well
from you know hitting into the hip and
also back into the femur so you know so
you don't snap off your
uh femoral head which is a really bad
injury
so it's it's a yeah so it's a good way
to distribute so we have all these
struts too and they've shown that yeah
okay the struts and runners look
different than the struts and you know
your average joe that just maybe walks
to work
um
so we look different on the inside
depending on what we're doing and those
definitely remodel over our lifetime so
that's so neat
uh i'm
of
i don't think i'm alone in this a lot of
us have been sitting around more since
cove had started
and now things are starting to open up
we're all getting out and doing things
you know here actually here i'm i'm in
quebec i'm in canada and for a while we
weren't even supposed to go outside
except for within certain hours of the
day
um and then
i have dogs and there was an exception
for anyone with dogs you can you can be
with your dog taking on a walk
it was
that sort of extreme
lockdown only happened for a little bit
and then people realize that's that's
kind of crazy people need to go outside
and get fresh air but
honestly i stopped going outside nearly
as much as i used to i just kind of got
into this lazy habit and now i'm going
out and doing stuff do i need to be
careful when i'm running around
like could i now break a bone easier
than before
does atrophy happen that quickly
uh actually can happen that quickly but
you're a young guy and you probably
don't have to worry about it to that
point if it was
um like an 80 year old woman who's been
like i'm gonna go and start jogging
tomorrow like i'd be like and chill out
grandma like just take it slow at the
beginning and you know and give your
bones a chance to catch up i think you
don't really actually have anything to
worry about but
that is a good point because i mean
myself included i've been sitting on you
know sitting a whole lot more i've been
inside the whole time and while i'm in
germany right now
um or before at the beginning of the
lockdown we had pretty much the same
thing but they gave us an hour of
outside time not actually enforceable
obviously but
they basically said the same thing you
know everyone's allowed an hour but you
have to be masked and you have to do
this and you have to do that
um
and and in the end you know i fell into
a rut where i didn't move much either
um
so being inside long periods of time
and not doing much and being quite
sedentary
uh has actually two two digits um and it
impacts your bones in two ways first
you're actually not getting enough
vitamin d
uh because you're in you're inside um
which is horrible for your mood it
causes all kind it's been linked to
depression and all that kind of stuff
but it's also been super linked to
your bone not knowing how to metabolize
your calcium so say you're getting
enough calcium it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if you don't have the
metabolically active version of vitamin
d which means
any calcium you're taking in you are pee
working out and good luck like it won't
actually it won't actually help you so
that's the first and horrible you know
impact to our bones uh from staying
inside then the second thing is that
yeah your muscles are not acting on your
bones they're not giving you that
pressure they're not telling your bones
hey i'm being used please keep
remodeling this area as were
and
our skeleton is always trying to
optimize itself it takes away from areas
that aren't being used and adds to areas
that are being used so if you're not
using your legs all the time or
um your arms or you know you're not
exercising uh it's not great for your
skeleton your skeleton's like oh okay i
heard you really don't need this stuff
let's let's lighten the load
and that's not what we want
now this
i mean the skeleton sort of acts like an
intelligent system
right it's it's it's finding ways to
optimize itself
is this all do we understand
and i guess we don't understand all the
rules that are happening but this this
must just be happening as individual
cells are communicating with each other
and just obeying
fairly simple rules like if then
statements essentially if you're waiting
about programming totally yeah yeah
how many mysteries are there
do you think that we still just don't
understand or
has has that communication system been
well understood like do we know the if
then statements
um to to a pretty big extent yes in some
ways because we have a lot of drugs that
act on these if then statements
basically like
if right if hormone rankle is present uh
osteoblast is deactivated if osteoblast
is deactivated it turns off its like
system it's basically like coding it's
exactly like biological coding right so
when one cell turns off its system it
changes its keys and it can no longer be
activated can only be activated when you
turn on a different key
and that kind of stuff has actually been
mapped out relatively well in humans
um
because yeah because of the way we want
drugs to act we want to understand
um
how our kidneys function our bones and
our skeletons actually super intertwined
with our kidneys our liver our adrenal
system
um and recently there was a paper that
came out i think it was last year that
showed that
the um
the skeleton is involved in your
fight-or-flight response which i thought
was super cool yeah
yeah so because our skeleton is tied in
with how our kidneys work and other
hormones are actually produced in
the skeleton uh apparently one of those
is uh
is responsible for your like flight
response which i thought was super cool
yeah
wow so there's a lot of stuff that's
still to be discovered like this which
was just discovered last year or well
was just published last year um and then
other things that are pretty well known
like our remodeling cycle is pretty well
known we know how to
um kind of try to slow it down so people
you know will
increase estrogen in older women and
that helps slow down the over remodeling
so that only happened because we
actually understand that system quite
well there is this problem that uh women
after menopause have which is that the
weakening of the hips well i don't know
is it the whole skeleton or is it just
it's the whole skeleton it's the whole
skeleton
so
why is that unique to women or seem to
be unique to women
good question so because our remodeling
cycle is actually related to our
estrogen cycle
when women go through menopause um
they
lose the certain amount of estrogen that
they were already making
so that loss
basically
that one the estrogen was the off key
for your osteoclasts the cells that that
um eat bone
it's it's yeah so they're
yeah basically so they are
the estrogen was one step in one of
those multi-chain reactions that then
turns off those bone eating cells so
when you lose that off switch your bone
eating cells are going
basically too far they're doing their
job too well and there's nothing to
check them
so that's why women have that problem
why we see most of those issues in the
hips and the back like you like you
mentioned is because we're bipedal all
right that's where most of our pressure
actually goes we that's where our like
basically center of gravity is mostly
it's your
lumbar um
vertebrae as they get weaker they kind
of compress and that's why older people
get shorter
we actually lose like bone mass and they
you know get shorter and they get the
hunched back and all that that's from
deformation of the vertebrae
so that's all because of those links and
it's all because
our remodeling system is just going
too much
compared to the building system which is
just not going as fast because we're
aging so it's kind of a double whammy
and
are you saying that is that that's fully
treatable now or is it partially
treatable it's it's only partially
tradable because like everything nothing
is super easy
so even if
so there are some estrogen supplements
and stuff like that i'm not a doctor by
the way anyone that is watching
um not a medical doctor
but i've studied this quite a bit so
one of the issues is okay for example
and not that doctors have suggested this
but for example let's say we replace
estrogen to formally normal levels
all the other parts of
menopause are still active so your body
actually doesn't know what to do with
all the extra estrogen and that has been
linked with increased levels of breast
cancer and cervical cancer and uterine
cancer
so
it's kind of an interesting balancing
act and now it's much more treatable
where you they encourage young women
like myself
to go and get a baseline bone stand so
they can you know kind of monitor the
next 30 years
so my grandma
it was i just watched her suffer through
this it was horrible because she had to
have a hip replacement and
she ended up
getting frustrated with the cast and she
cut it off herself and it healed wrong
and the last like five years of her life
she was
just
in agony
super pain
and um
first of all yeah it was just so
frustrating because you know watching
this amazing woman have to go through
this
her doctor was telling her that
when it first started happening is that
she needed to do more exercise because
that would fix it but you're saying that
this is a hormonal thing exercise would
it probably should help a little bit but
there's going to be a limit to that
right
right so exercise does help and exercise
does change our hormones so
which i mean exercise helps with several
things that are hormonal problems and
actually can cause other
uh issues with hormonal problems because
our muscles help with regulating certain
um hormones our bones help with
regulating certain hormones it
definitely would have helped but like
you said um there's definitely a limit
to certain things but so is there for
medication you know there's a limit to
that so what they're trying to do is
combine you know the limit of the
medication plus the limit of the
exercise hopefully that will you know
keep it at bay enough that
you have a comfortable enough life as
you go as you grow older
yeah actually sorry i actually think it
was her knee but just they had a
titanium knee pudding yeah but it was it
was due to menopause uh degeneration so
that's interesting
how much has our understanding of
remodeling changed interpretations of
the fossil record
has that had a huge impact on
what we thought we knew i would say yes
absolutely basically with the
evidence that comes from histology so
histology is the study of tissues and
paleohistology is the study of extinct
tissues and that's what i do i'm a paleo
histologist so the way that we look at
these extinct tissues we take the fossil
and we you know glue it on a slide we
cut it off and grind it really thin
and then we can see through it and
actually see cell structures and bone
structures
etcetera so now once that method became
pretty commonly used in paleontology
we realized
that
all these extinct animals don't have the
same amount of remodeling and the amount
of remodeling is related to
the amount of metabolism so this was
kind of already known in modern animals
but uh it leaked into paleontology and
that's definitely changed uh quite a few
things for a long time people thought
t-rex and sauropods those long-necked
dinosaurs and stegosaurs and you know
all the those things were big lumbering
you know
just slow beasts and yeah
exactly cold-blooded people thought
something about ichthyosaurs and all
those marine reptiles you know moses
everyone thought you know those must
have been slow just cold-blooded blah
things and and the reason we know a lot
of that is because we studied the bones
and study the histology of it the
tissues and we see that
they're actually remodeling their bone
closer to
mammals and birds
rather than modern reptiles and
crocodiles and all those like the slow
lumbering beasts kind of thing yeah so
that completely you know phase shifted
our our understanding to
oh
like these were you know active animals
that grew quickly that you know fit into
their environment differently
it doesn't only just change the way that
you think of the animal but it also
makes you think of their environment
differently yeah if this animal had to
sustain such a high metabolism how much
did it actually eat you know how many
trees really took did it take to sustain
a brachiosaurus really right because
they're different when you look at their
bones so
yeah it definitely definitely changed
our thoughts and on top of that i'll
talk about one extra really cool thing
there's a very specific type of
remodeling that's known to modern birds
and it's called uh or the type of bone
called medullary bone it's bone that's
in the center of
a long bone so think of your legs or
your arm we have a like a jewelry cavity
a cavity where your red blood cells are
made it's a hollow area and that's
normal
but in certain birds during breeding
season when they're getting ready to lay
eggs before they lay eggs they actually
store a ton of calcium
in there
and then they re-release it
into their eggs
and that's how they make sure that they
don't sacrifice their own skeleton while
laying a ton of eggs yeah and this is
pretty well known in modern birds they
re-uh model the inside they take it back
out and they put it in their
eggs and then so you can actually tell
okay that chicken when i got that bone
it was an eggling chicken versus not you
can actually see it with like your naked
eye you don't need a microscope or
anything it's like pretty drastic change
now the cool thing is that we've seen
that in dinosaurs
so
so in like um t-rex and other theropods
you we found medullary bone so we know
that they were investing physiologically
a lot into these eggs and a lie to these
kids um or their offspring
because think of how big that animal is
and how much calcium it's actually
storing and we're so lucky to catch it
you know in the act of storing calcium
but it tells us about their biology
tells us possibly about their behavior i
mean
of course it doesn't tell us if they had
parental care or not because we still
don't know but it's still pretty
interesting and it informs our our ideas
on these extinct animals a whole lot
yeah that is really neat
things you can learn just from looking
at bones
i know right i'm trying to teach the
gospel that's what i'm saying
let's talk about how bone remodeling the
actual process has changed over time so
you've done research specifically in
when did these different types of bone
cells emerge throughout evolutionary
history
and you just published a big paper on
that
yeah do you want to talk about that for
a little bit here sure absolutely
this this kind of comes from
reading you know the early textbooks of
biology and just you know learning okay
a b and c
this is what happens this is how bones
this is how bones do
the end
and then i was like okay cool we we know
how bones do and then i made the mistake
of looking at fish
uh and it was a mistake because fish are
incredibly complicated and they stem
from way before tetrapods right so they
come way down farther in the tree than
than we do and so that doesn't mean
they're more primitive at least modern
fish does not mean they're more
primitive it just means they took a
different branch of life and they had a
different tool set to work with so
everything turns out everything looks
really different in fish and they just
play by their own rules which makes my
life really complicated
yeah so
i saw what fish modern fish were doing i
saw what you know modern mammals us and
reptiles and every i think everything is
alive today we're doing and i wanted to
just trace it back and see when certain
divergence divergences happen
so to understand to understand why
this is cool i have to
give you guys a little bit of bone 101
yeah so
one quick question first what what group
of fish were you looking at chilios bony
bony fish basically the ones that make
up
the vast majority so think tuna think
salmons think
uh oppa not sharks so like bony fish the
ones that you would that would end up on
your dinner table nothing extremely
special nothing extremely specialized
and they were still doing everything
really differently
than
than all the textbooks said because
apparently nobody looks at fish
so
when you're looking for these rules that
are supposed to guide all bone you know
like
you you they have to apply to all
animals that have bone otherwise they're
not rules and
therefore you have to dig deeper and for
me digging deeper means digging deeper
in time
so
bone 101
so you got to know that basically
there's three bone cell types that you
just have to keep in mind there's the
bone building cells
osteoblasts
your bone destroying cells your
osteoclasts
and your osteocytes which i call your
bone maintaining cells are the ones that
kind of keep everyone in line they
orchestrate bone remodeling they
orchestrate uh a bunch of different
things they sense pressure in your bone
they kind of they live in the bone and
they have think of squid arms or octopus
arms and they reach out everywhere so
there's a bunch of those and they're the
most numerous so there's your three cell
types
now
all books say that they'll show you
three cell types
one and done
that's it
right so it's pretty insane that
the vast majority of living vertebrates
today
the vast majority
don't have ostriches and all of the fish
all of those are booty fish which is
just like
come on you guys like you cannot follow
a single roll like rude
so i looked back in time and realized
they did have osteocytes um at some
point in the cretaceous and then lost it
and some things lost it even more
recently we're not a 100 sure there's a
couple of new papers that are coming out
about exactly when certain things were
lost anyway they come from ancestors
that had osteocytes
yeah okay great great we're back to
following the rules but if you go back
just even a little bit farther before
jaws evolved before
limbs evolve before any of that so
you're looking at mud slurping jawless
fish early devonian solarian the
earliest vertebrates armored jawless
fish and you look at them the earliest
ones again don't have osteocytes
and
they don't have visible osteonal
remodeling the type of a model that we
talked about earlier that's guided by
uh your blood vessels
okay they don't have it it doesn't exist
okay
so now we know that all our bones and
all the all the superpowers that our
modern bone has hasn't always existed
but they were acquired through evolution
and possibly in a stepwise fashion
possibly all at once with one animal
we're still not 100 sure when you look a
little bit later there's another jawless
fish that has osteocytes and has a bunch
of other features that makes us think
okay those are the ancestors to jaw
invertebrates and then from those the
earliest jawed vertebrates are the ones
that have osteonal remodeling and from
there you get you know all your splits
of cartilaginous fish and raven fish and
all the fish that we have today and then
star crop terrains the lobe fin fish the
ones that lead eventually to us
tetrapods
the story of bone is basically the story
of vertebrates it starts right at the
beginning
uh with a really extremely
simplified external armor they look like
beetles they have only bone on the
outside they don't have any bone on the
inside oh i did not know that okay they
have no bone on the inside it's a
cartilaginous skeleton on the inside
bone on the outside only and the bone on
the outside is covered in
pause for effect
dentine
which is what our teeth are made of yeah
which is crazy
so the first tissues that make our teeth
today actually started out as ways that
our
mud slurping ancestors protected
themselves
yeah so that's the story of bone that's
the story of teeth they're all
interconnected and
i got asked a really good question which
is why
you know
why
did they need all this armor why do they
need to put teeth on the outside and
bone why did bone evolve in the first
place right you get to that point where
okay so not everything existed not all
the features existed why did the very
first
mud slurping fish even evolve what was
the point you know maybe they were happy
to be soft squirmy wormy things why did
why didn't we just continue down that
road
and the the answer is very likely
because of euripids these giant sea
scorpions
that try to basically eat our early
vertebrate ancestors and they're like
this is not this is not how we're doing
this i would rather be armored and
survive thank you
and that's how vertebrate mineralization
likely started from that predation
pressure
so we can thank scorpions and arachnids
for our skeletons basically that's what
i'm trying to say
nice
nice
okay editor john here
what yara i just said there is so
important that i just i have to restate
it not because you didn't state it well
enough but because it's so important i
want people to to really understand this
it appears that our skeletons and our
teeth the molecular precursors the genes
that we now use to build our skeletons
in our teeth
those evolved during an arms race
with ancient marine arthropods or again
as yara put it
so we can thank scorpions and arachnids
for our skeletons basically is what i'm
trying to say
so the the first skeletons in
vertebrates were exoskeletons as well
exactly that's really cool yes
isn't it
sharks still have like teeth things on
their
teeth like scales sharks do am i
right you got it you're right but also
sharks stem from a bony um ancestor and
they just lost their bone secondarily
so
they come from that first jawed ancestor
the one that had jaws that had an
exoskeleton but also some internal
uh mineralization
and
sharks just secondarily lost it and we
think of sharks as being so primitive
because they're cartilaginous fish but
actually much like modern fish that
don't have osteoslice that's a secondary
feature that's a derived feature for
them that happened later um they did
keep the chief on the outside though
because they're cool like that yeah
and so so we have the evolution of bone
on the outside and then somehow the
genes that were involved in that ended
up also distributing bone
around the
the vertebr the spinal cord and so on
is
do we start to see modern looking-ish
um skeletons is it does it start at the
spine or the brain case like what what
is the first thing that we see
ossifying in us today we have two types
of bone called endochondral bone and
dermal bone so dermal bone is what makes
up all your skulls like your skull bones
are all dermal bone
and endochondral bone is your internal
from from the word you can tell endo
inside chondral cartilate or cartilage
and then bone so cartilage based
internal bone
and that's how our um
limbs and everything form they form from
first they are they make cartilage and
then bone invades the cartilage and
basically takes over that shape and
ossifies that shape
uh more or less i mean it's a little bit
more complicated but that's endochondral
bone dermal bone is from our early mud
slurping ancestors that's what the
exoskeleton was and that's what
eventually became our skull bones so we
still have dermal bone okay we still
have that stuff that
they came up with from the beginning and
figured it out so the very first
mineralization was you know yeah your
your brain case and your scope because
that's what they had i mean it was an
exoskeleton but it was also mostly their
skull
and then after that it was the vertebrae
which
started with something called
perichondrium ossification which all
that means is
um
think of like an orange peel so it's
only an orange peel of bone that lives
on the outside of a cartilaginous
vertebrae and so they had that
and then eventually they had fully
ossified uh vertebrae and lin like fins
and all other kinds of uh fun
ossifications that led us to the weird
skeletons we have today
okay that's really interesting that
okay so i have i have a wiener dog and
her
kind
is really prone they've got a mutation
that's someone liked because it made
them look longer but it can also cause
the cartilage plates between the
backbones
to ossify they partially ossify and they
become super brittle
and then they break and squirt liquid
out and it causes major pain for the
animals so the a lot of them have to be
put down when they're young
it's absolutely horrible that this
happens but what i find interesting
about this is that
a relatively small mutation in this case
is actually a gene duplication
it can
cause something that evolves to exist in
one part of the skeleton
or one part of the body to get
superimposed on a totally different part
of the body
and
you you have this transfer of traits
from one place to another
just because of a point or in this case
a gene duplication
that's so interesting to me because
you've got this what used to be an
exoskeleton and is now internalized
that could have happened with actually
if probably a fairly simple mutation
could have caused a switch like that
but if it was a big change at once
probably would have been weird
early on so
but it
you're saying that the skull is
essentially an exoskeleton but of course
we have skin on the outside of our
skulls
was there a switch that had to happen
there or did these early exoskeletons
actually have a thin layer of skin on
the outside too do we think
so
we do think that they likely had some
soft tissue on the outside and the only
reason we think that is because they
have sensory um pores and sensory canals
that are part of that exoskeleton i mean
it's not really an exoskeleton it's just
a giant skull and a fish body attached
to it but they look like beetles they
look crazy um yeah
and they do have sensory pores you know
they had elect like we think it's
probably either to sense differences in
pressure in the water or differences in
um
like ion gradients or maybe any any of
those we really don't know but somehow
those would have had to be protected you
really because because they lived um
they were like bottom dwellers you know
they were flat on the bottom and had
like a dome top kind of almost like a
flat fish or a stargazer that we know
today um they lived in these shallow
seas and they kind of that so you don't
really want sand rubbing up rubbing up
against your you know sensitive pores or
whatever right so very likely um they
had soft tissue also we see that um when
they are attacked they're healing these
exoskeletons these dermal bones so to
heal dermal bone you have to have some
amount of cells actually reaching the
wound site so very likely they had um
some kind of soft tissue that covered it
that's really interesting so you're
saying that the the skull
started to ossify before even the the
backbone did yeah yep that's really cool
i mean it kind of makes sense right
we're cranates i mean where we come from
animals that if you know the when it
comes to divisions of animalia like we
came from things that formed a very
distinct head and we clearly care about
our head and it's you know our control
panel we don't really have a
decentralized nervous system like some
animals do you know uh we have a very
centralized nervous system so
you want to protect that and it's very
likely that that actually started with
some of these early jawless fish because
we have
um
like basically um
almost like an endocast of what their
brain would have looked like because
this
exoskeleton or this this dermal bone
wrapped around what would have been
their nerval nerves and and brain and
all that so tightly that we can actually
figure out what shape it was so we knew
that they actually did have a
brain like system and we can actually
trace nerve nerve canals and stuff it's
quite detailed and they preserve really
beautifully i've been really interested
in how dental occlusion
ends up forming so the way that teeth
match each other kind of like puzzle
pieces inside the mouth of an animal and
we see this happening in sort of like a
kind of a
maybe you would say a primitive way even
in crocodiles so their their teeth kind
of
go past each other
and they seem to be pushing each other
around actually they're growing down
from the top and up from the bottom and
when they connect to each other they
push each other outwards and
there's a time lapse floating around on
the internet of braces i don't know if
you've ever seen this but it's just
you start out with crazy teeth
and the braces just pull everything and
it it's it's amazing how fluid bone is
spectacular
here i have
this is a
a
blown up version of a vampire bat
yeah they're crazy
their incisors are insane yeah
these incisors are crazy and there's a
little pocket
of
that that captures those incisors in the
bottom jaw so it's like pressure from
those teeth caused the bone to move out
of the way
it really looks like that's what
happened because it it fits like a
sheath they got a really tough soft
tissue covering there as well but it
looks like as the animal is growing it's
just constant pressure on that bone
caused the bone to move out of the way
how
how how much of that how much
am i right in thinking this is the yeah
is it just pressure
yeah so so i mean i don't think it's 100
pressure i think there's definitely some
sort of um genetic precursor that just
tells like bone to not grow as much
there and then secondarily reacts to
pressure being there or presence being
there or a certain amount of tissue
being there that's definitely true and
we can see it like happening in real
time like you said with braces um
and that happens for several reasons so
so
all the teeth that you showed me today
are not attached to bone they're
actually attached to a ligament that's
then attached to bone
so if you kind of like press down on
your teeth a little bit you kind of feel
them like springing there's a bit of
give
and that's because we have something
called a periodontial ligament which is
just your mouth ligament and it holds
the teeth into its bony socket
and
that is where the interaction happens
between the ligament and the bone and so
slowly but surely what braces do is that
you know the wire will pull the tooth
this way so you're constantly pushing a
tooth against the ligament this way and
pulling this way so the the ligament is
for example pulling on the bone in one
direction and therefore
causing the bone to grow in that
direction more and resorb from the other
side so the pressure is definitely truly
remodeling the inside of your mouth
which is what braces do it's pretty
crazy yeah and
likewise the lack of pressure also
causes rebound so this is why if um
if you lose your teeth so like people
who are completely edentulous completely
lost all their teeth doctors will still
um
recommend that you get dentures even if
you you know even if you don't want to
they recommend you wear dentures as much
as possible because that pressure is
really important to keep your mandibles
the right shape if you ever look at an
old person's like from medieval times or
before all this you look at their skulls
you can tell it's an old person their
mandibles are much thinner it literally
looks like they're curling in on each
other because the bone doesn't have that
pressure anymore and i assume the same
thing would happen with like dogs that
have those groups you know for their
upper canines they have those juices
probably same thing with the vampire bat
i would assume it's probably the same
thing if you they somehow lost their
incisors i bet you if they lived long
enough without an incisor um they would
probably refill those bones uh those
like holes so like i have all four of my
wisdom teeth removed
i had a scan done recently because i
thought i had a cavity and i saw that
the area that my wisdom teeth were
removed is no longer
just it's not a hole it's just bone has
gone in and filled that up because
there's no pressure there to to maintain
that alveolus or the bone or the hole
that the teeth were in
so the lack of pressure causes bones to
sometimes fill in and sometimes a lack
of pressure causes over resorption it
just depends where in the skeleton it's
happening so you're totally right yeah
this um so this is the peruvian skull
she was
probably in her 60s is what they think
she's missing a bunch of molars and her
wisdom teeth have moved forward to uh
like it did just with all that space it
just moved around a lot it's it's really
interesting to see
it yeah i mean i i envy you because you
know you were working are you still
working in a museum
yeah
yeah you get to look at this stuff and
just think about it all the time every
day you know
that's why i've i've collected these
skulls over the years it's it's just
there's so many weird things you just
pick up on
if you're surrounded by these things
and if you actually look i mean there's
plenty of people that you know will hold
something oh yeah that's cool and then
like move on
uh but then you're staring at these
little features and you're asking these
important questions and that's why i
definitely encourage people to you know
like if you find a skull in the forest
like keep it stare at that thing it's
weird like
ask questions
it's important um but yeah i mean that's
why i love working at a museum whenever
i feel not inspired i just go into
collections and i find 10 more projects
so yeah
it was it was really neat working at the
wildlife center because i would
you know we would have
injured animals
everyone's like oh my gosh you're such a
good person you care about these animals
but i was really just curious about
their anatomy and
[Laughter]
i could get close to them without them
running away because they were injured
so it was kind of uh
i had had a different reason for being
there than other people i was just
fascinated in these things
but the
one of the really weird things was
we had um
we'd have birds that would come in
they'd have a broken humerus
and it would rip out of the tissue
if it was dried
if the bone tips were dry they were
screwed
you would have to cut off until it's wet
again and then put that together
and if one wing is shorter than the
other
i'm useless yeah sometimes sometimes
we would hunt them and we had a big
hunting yard where we could see if they
could still hunt and catch prey and
stuff before we let them go sometimes
they would relearn that oh i have to fly
harder with this wing because
it's shorter sometimes it would not so
we would go through this whole process
of reviving them
going through surgery and then we just
euthanized in many ways it was it was
horrible
but
it's amazing what an animal can recover
from and
you know that that bone is really
working hard trying to fix itself even
in a bur you'd think that a bird
wouldn't be able to survive a broken
wing ever
but they do they
they heal
i mean with with human health for sure i
mean bone will will keep healing as long
as it's being you know um as long as
like you said the two pieces are vital
so they stop circulation and they still
have the periosteum with what they're
asking for when they're saying it's dry
means the periosteum has peeled off and
all the vessels are gone and it's it's
basically dead bone so putting that back
in is like necrotic tissue and it's not
a good time
so
bone will keep doing what bone does and
try to fix itself as long as the animal
is still getting enough nutrients the
question is is it going to be able to
function
uh and
and that's always difficult to tell
without giving the animal a shot right
like it's it's hard it must be such a
hard call to make
yeah i mean after they've been doing it
for a few years there's always someone
who knows that one's gonna make it that
one's not well like doesn't know but
it's
certain enough that we're not gonna
spend all of our resources on an animal
that's not gonna end up making it but
yeah it's it was a really neat
it was a really neat project and i also
got to work with we had a a beetle box
so we would take if it was a specimen
that was really interesting we'd take it
and put it in the that had died we would
put it in the beetle box and then we'd
use the skeleton for educational stuff
and
birds are the most fascinating thing and
just
when i was preparing a body you'd you
know you'd remove the feathers and just
to see how the whole feather structure
works it's so intricately entwined with
the even with the skeletal system the
flight feathers are
yeah really neat to see that they touch
right into the ulna it's pretty crazy
those like um
what is it called shoot
whatever yeah those like bumps that they
have on the ulna that show that there
were flight feathers i mean we have that
in fossils too that's how we know that
some of the early like um
i forget which ones but basically those
like
ostrich mimics
those ones have all kinds of we we know
that they probably had big feathers
whether they were actually functional as
anything is is not the point but they
definitely haven't because we have the
osteological correlation
um but yeah i mean working with bones
and working with
like even though it seems morbid to most
people but i think we we know better
but like working with
like the bodies of these animals that
you've
you know you've read about as a kid or
you've seen in documentaries or you've
seen outside but never got to be like
that close up to it and seeing how
all these pieces actually fit together
and like like you said the feather is
laying on top of each other so perfectly
yeah and knowing that they molt them
every year and they're still like so
perfect it's just crazy and yeah and
that's the coolest part about biology
right yeah we are the
vertebrates are just the most amazing
things
i think you're just going to make a lot
of invert people really upset
well
of course of course a vertebrate would
think that vertebrates are cool right
there is a vertebrate bias i mean yeah
well um
do you have any
are there any like just burning things
that you think the world has to know
about skeletons
that we haven't covered yet
i guess like i want everyone to know
that like
that skel that our skeletons are
absolutely amazing because
they are living lattices they are living
structures and while we're not the first
to invent skeletons i mean sponges have
skeletons crabs technically have
skeletons you know exoskeletons
we're not the first to invent
mineralizing something to support our
bodies or to support our muscles as
vertebrates we are not but we are
definitely the first to
invent a living structure that adapts to
what we do
in real time in like our lives because
snails have a skeleton and sponges have
a skeleton but they can't remodel it
once it's made it's dead
um but ours listens to us and changes
with our needs which
i think is what makes our skeletons
really unique and i think that's why you
picked up on
remodeling as like your main topic
because it's such a it's such an
interesting topic
it is what makes us special
yeah i think we have this false idea
that a skeleton is just like a dead rock
inside of us right um
bone is but it just
i mean you were saying that your your
bones rebuild themselves
until you're like seven yeah i know well
even after you basically get a fresh new
skeleton every seven to ten years
because just because of you know the
calculation goes like i think you
remodel like
however many grams of bone each day and
then they just scaled it up to time and
how much in your skeleton and so
our skeletons are working really hard
for us to make sure that you know you
don't have the same bone that you're
you're born with because it has all the
micro cracks every step you've ever
taken everything you've ever lifted
creates strain in your skeleton and
creates all these micro cracks and it
wants you to have
fresh new bones to work with every few
years so certain areas of our body
remodel faster than others depending on
the strains and probably the best thing
you can do for your skeleton is eat
right see some sun and uh
just take a walk every now and again and
it'll serve you well
that's cool
well
yara thank you for coming on this was
amazing this seriously this was this was
better is it everything you wanted it's
better than i thought it'd be yeah
um
i
i
i guess my message for um for people on
on bones would be to uh
a lot of people
tell kids not to look at you know the
dead body on the the dead cat on the
side of the road and stuff like that
if if the kid's interested let them look
yeah make make them poke it
yeah let them poke it yeah
maybe use a stick if it's really rotten
fine but if it's a little squishy makes
sense but yeah i mean encourage
encourage curiosity into osteology and i
mean all natural things has definitely
always been my message i'm glad you
agree
yeah well thank you this has been great
yeah absolutely no it was really fun and
i love talking with bones
and that is it my friends
yara haridi i do recommend that you
follow her on twitter if you're on
twitter i don't know if she has facebook
and all that other stuff too but
her twitter is pretty good she's always
posting cool stuff on there so check
that out
you